- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La première
va être posée par madame
la présidente
Mathilde Panot pour LFI.
- Mathilde Panot:
Madame la Première ministre,
hier, vous avez été
défaits,
vous et tous les semeurs de haine.
Votre loi immigration
a été battue
par l'Assemblée.
Hier, nous avons épargné
au pays
deux semaines de déchaînement
de paroles racistes
et xénophobes,
celles qui divisent
le peuple, qui permettaient
les passages
à l'acte.
Hier comme demain,
nous serons toujours
les gardiens de l'unité du peuple.
Hier,
nous sommes fiers
de vous avoir rappelé
que la France n'a jamais été
une nation ethnique
mais sera toujours
une nation politique
fondée sur la promesse
de liberté, égalité et fraternité.
Hier, vous avez été
défaits,
et après un président
élu par défaut,
vous voilà à la tête
d'un gouvernement minoritaire
et sans légitimité
parlementaire
ni populaire.
Votre ministre
de l'Intérieur a parlé
de "déni de démocratie".
Le déni de démocratie, c'est vous!
20 49.3, 2 ans volés au peuple!
Madame la Première
ministre, sans 49.3,
vous n'êtes rien.
Vous êtes incapable
de légiférer
et de gouverner.
Hier, vous avez osé dire
que l'Assemblée s'était déshonorée
et ne représentait pas
les Français.
Mais les Français veulent
des augmentations
de salaire,
des services publics
qui assurent l'égalité
des citoyens.
Ils veulent en finir
avec un gouvernement
qui a fait régresser la France.
Dans toutes les
démocraties,
quand un ministre est battu,
il doit démissionner.
Quand la représentation
nationale rejette
un texte, il doit être retiré.
Sentez-vous cette odeur
de fin de règne,
madame la ministre?
Vous serez contraint
de retourner
aux urnes.
Le peuple devra
choisir entre le camp
des élites racistes et celui
des unions populaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Votre temps est écoulé.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs,
madame Mathilde Panot,
hier,
une fois de plus,
vous vous êtes coalisés
avec le Rassemblement National.
Hier,
une fois de plus,
vous avez fait
le choix délibéré
de la compromission
avec l'extrême droite.
Vous Vous qui souhaitez
l'immigration
sans règle, vous avez voté
l'immigration zéro!
Brouhaha
Vous qui souhaitez
des régularisations
massives,
vous avez voté
avec ceux qui prônent
la fermeture des frontières.
Malgré vos tentatives
d'empêcher
la discussion,
le débat parlementaire
va se poursuivre.
Une commission
mixte paritaire
va être convoquée,
malgré vos tentatives
pour empêcher le débat.
Nous ne renoncerons pas
à apporter
des mesures fortes
pour nos concitoyens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Un peu de silence!
- Elisabeth Borne:
Le débat,
ça n'est pas pour vous.
Madame Mathilde
Panot, hormis
quelques secondes...
Brouhaha
Vous êtes fâchée
avec la démocratie,
madame la présidente
Mathilde Panot.
Et votre groupe avec!
Applaudissements
Madame la présidente
Panot, hormis
quelques secondes
de satisfaction
à l'Assemblée
et quelques minutes
de présence dans les médias,
qu'avez-vous obtenu?
Madame Mathilde Panot,
par votre attitude
et celle
de votre groupe,
ceux qui sont pénalisés,
ce sont les Français,
qui soutiennent
très largement
notre texte.
Les Français attendent
que nous prenions
des mesures fortes pour réduire
l'immigration illégale
et pour mieux intégrer
les personnes
que nous choisissons d'accueillir.
Les Français veulent
que nous trouvions
des compromis,
pas des coups politiques.
Mais vous, que leur proposez-vous?
Le blocage
de nos institutions
et une union sacrée
entre la NUPES
et l'extrême droite.
Vous ne leur proposez
que le chaos.
C'est irresponsable et dangereux.
Avec Gérald Darmanin et tous
nos gouvernements,
nous choisirons
toujours le chemin
de l'action
et de la responsabilité
au service des Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Applaudissements
La parole est à monsieur
le président Boris Vallaud
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Boris Vallaud:
Madame la présidente,
madame la Première
ministre,
depuis 18 mois, nous avons,
dans cet hémicycle,
au Sénat, dans la presse
ou en commission,
débattu de l'immigration.
Le débat a bien eu lieu.
Nous y avons largement
participé,
pour notre part.
Nous avons cherché
les moyens de remettre
le bon ordre
dans le grand désert
de votre politique migratoire.
Nous voulons
régulariser celles
et ceux qui travaillent
déjà ici, mettre
en route l'intégration
républicaine.
Mais le texte que le gouvernement
voulait défendre
était très éloigné des positions
d'Emmanuel Macron
que nous avons fait élire
par deux fois face
à l'extrême droite.
Il était très éloigné
de sa version initiale.
Il était aveugle à la question
de l'intégration,
sans équilibre s'agissant
des questions d'éloignement.
Il était plus qu'un
mauvais texte
de loi de police des étrangers.
Hier, votre ministre a échoué.
Ce n'est pas la gauche
qui vous précipite
dans les bras de la droite
qui elle-même,
se précipite dans les bras
de l'extrême droite.
Le pacte funeste,
c'est celui fait
au Sénat par votre ministre
avec l'extrême droite.
La crise
politique
n'est pas dans le rejet
de votre texte
mais dans le passage
en force,
dans l'hystérisation du débat.
Dans le fait de ne pas croire
à la possibilité
d'un débat apaisé et rationnel
qui permet d'envisager
des consensus républicains.
Madame la Première
ministre,
je vous le demande
sans outrance,
sans cris, sans la satisfaction
du spectacle
de la chute:
retirez
ce texte avant
d'être sur une pente
qui mène
vers un territoire
qui n'est pas le vôtre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs,
monsieur le président Boris
Vallaud.
Hier, vous avez fait
un choix lourd
de conséquences.
Pour un coup politique
sans lendemain,
vous avez mis de côté
vos convictions.
Vous avez
choisi de mêler vos voix
à celles de l'extrême droite.
Vous avez mis de côté
des décennies d'histoire
du Parti Socialiste
pour refuser
le débat, en vous appuyant
sur le Rassemblement National.
Vous étiez un parti
de gouvernement.
Hier, vous avez fait le choix
de l'irresponsabilité.
Vous ne cessez d'invoquer
la démocratie parlementaire
et le rôle de l'Assemblée
nationale.
C'est vous qui avez balayé
d'un revers
de main le texte adopté
par la commission
des lois.
C'est vous qui empêchez
le débat
sur les 2600 amendements
que nous devions étudier ensemble.
Monsieur le président
Boris Vallaud,
les Français demandent
des solutions face
aux défis migratoires.
Nous sommes déterminés
à les donner.
Nous gardons le cap
et vos manoeuvres n'y feront rien.
Une commission
mixte paritaire
va être convoquée.
Nous ne renoncerons
jamais à apporter
les solutions attendues
par les Français:
la fermeté face
à l'immigration irrégulière
et une meilleure
intégration des personnes
que nous accueillons.
Avec la majorité,
nous continuerons
à agir pour apporter des réponses.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Edwige Diaz
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Edwige Diaz: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
Hier, le "en même temps" si cher
à Emmanuel Macron
a montré ses limites.
Il s'est soldé
par un camouflet
pour votre gouvernement.
Les Français expriment
leur volonté d'une baisse
drastique
de l'immigration
dans votre pays:
vous ne les
avez pas écoutés
et vous avez au contraire proposé
un texte qui aurait
permis la création
de nouvelles filières
d'immigration,
la répartition
de migrants
dans nos campagnes
et la régularisation
des clandestins.
Voilà pourquoi
le Rassemblement National
a voté pour la motion de rejet.
Néanmoins,
il y avait des mesures
de bon sens dans ce texte.
Il y en a que
nous réclamons
depuis des années,
comme celle qui vise
à supprimer
les dérogations existantes
dans notre droit
qui empêchent d'expulser
un délinquant étranger.
Ce genre d'expulsion
constitue une priorité
pour votre gouvernement?
En 6 ans,
vous n'aurez pas été capables
de vous saisir de ce sujet
très préoccupant
pour nos concitoyens.
Marine Le Pen,
soucieuse de la sécurité
des Français, a déposé ce matin
un texte permettant
de lever ces dérogations.
D'après les déclarations
de nombreux collègues,
cette proposition de loi, elle,
devrait bénéficier
d'un soutien transpartisan.
Allez-vous
demander son étude
dans les prochains jours?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
Applaudissements
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs,
madame Diaz, s'il
y a bien eu
un "en même temps",
c'est entre le vote
du Rassemblement National
et celui de la NUPES.
Madame Diaz, le non-débat
d'hier a démontré
que vous avez peur du débat.
Vous n'avez pas voulu
parler d'immigration.
Vous en parlez
dans les meetings,
sur les marchés,
sur vos tracts
et sur les plateaux de télévision.
Vous n'en parlez jamais
devant la représentation
nationale.
Vous avez eu peur!
C'est tellement vrai
que votre belle unité
de façade entre vos ennemis
mélenchonistes
et vous-mêmes,
entre ceux qui veulent accueillir
tout le monde
et ceux qui ne veulent accueillir
personne, dès le lendemain,
vous proposez
les mêmes dispositions
que le gouvernement
pour lutter contre les étrangers
délinquants.
Trouvez l'erreur!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci.
Madame Diaz?
- Edwige Diaz:
Monsieur le ministre,
vous feignez
d'ignorer ce qu'est
une motion de rejet.
Les Français
continueront
de vous le reprocher.
J'ai une dernière question.
Qui a peur du débat?
C'est vous,
qui refusez de proposer
aux Français un référendum.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin:
Vous auriez pu débattre ici
et maintenant.
Vous auriez pu
accepter dès hier
le débat.
Vous êtes incohérents,
et comme d'habitude,
le RN voit des problèmes
et ne veut
aucune solution.
Vous avez désarmé
nos préfets, les Français,
et vous allez
vous réjouir au prochain
fait divers!
Vous faites la politique du déni.
Vous faites malheureusement
la politique
du pire.
Ce qui vous intéresse,
c'est la France
qui ne réussit pas.
Ce qui nous intéresse,
c'est la France
qui trouve des solutions.
Nous soutenons nos policiers,
gendarmes, préfets.
Vous faites de la politique
politicienne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Philippe Pradal.
- Philippe Pradal: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs,
madame la Première ministre,
chers collègues.
Le groupe Horizons est déçu.
Il est déçu que l'Assemblée
nationale ait été privée
d'un débat si important
pour la France
et les Français.
Nous sommes convaincus
que ce texte, voté
au Sénat et en commission
des lois, contient
des avancées
absolument nécessaires
pour notre pays,
pour notre sécurité
et notre souveraineté,
et plus encore
est conforme aux souhaits
de nos concitoyens.
La plupart des Français
sont favorables
à l'expulsion
des délinquants étrangers
à l'issue de leur peine de prison.
Ce projet est une pierre
indispensable
à l'édifice
de la réconciliation
entre le discours politique
et l'action publique.
Il donne les moyens
à l'administration
et à la justice de prendre
les décisions nécessaires
à la préservation
de notre cohésion sociale.
Une clique qui n'est d'accord
sur rien s'est coalisée
pour refuser le débat
dans cet hémicycle.
J'espère qu'une
majorité de convictions
va se dégager
pour adopter un texte
de responsabilité, d'efficacité.
Le groupe Horizons
et apparentés
le soutiendra.
Sur ce chemin sinueux,
nous devons
être à la hauteur
de notre devoir
et ne pas jouer
avec les fractures
de notre pays.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur,
ma question est la suivante.
Quel chemin emprunter
pour répondre
à l'inquiétude
légitime des Français
en matière de politique
migratoire
après l'adoption
de la motion
de rejet préalable hier?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Philippe Pradal,
je vous remercie
ainsi que monsieur
le rapporteur général.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame Martin!
Excusez-moi, monsieur le ministre.
Madame Martin, laissez
le ministre s'exprimer.
Sinon, je vous rappelle à l'ordre.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Je remercie
votre travail
en tant que rapporteur,
monsieur Pradal.
Vous l'avez dit,
c'est un texte soutenu
par les Français.
Ce qu'ont fait
hier une majorité
de députés,
c'est se mettre d'accord
pour que les Français
n'aient pas
de débat,
pour qu'ils n'aient pas
le texte qu'ils souhaitent
et se mettre d'accord
dans une coalition
des contraires,
sans majorité
alternative,
pour que les Français
ne connaissent
pas de solution
contre l'immigration irrégulière
et les étrangers délinquants.
Le texte est renvoyé en CMP.
Mais on a rejeté
le débat dans la chambre
qui est censée débattre.
On a fait perdre
du temps aux policiers,
aux gendarmes, aux préfets,
aux magistrats,
et on a désavoué leur travail.
Qui peut être contre l'examen
de réussite
en français
pour avoir un titre de séjour?
Qui peut refuser
d'interdire les mineurs
dans les centres
de rétention administrative?
Soyons fiers
de notre travail
et de nos convictions,
monsieur Philippe Pradal.
Ne laissons pas les autres
nous divertir.
Nous sommes là
parce que nous sommes conscients
que les Français
nous ont confié
la responsabilité
de porter nos convictions
et d'être durs
contre l'immigration irrégulière.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Philippe Pradal: Merci.
Le groupe Horizons
et apparentés sera fier
de vous soutenir
dans ces démarches.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Eric Ciotti
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Eric Ciotti: Merci.
Madame la présidente,
madame la Première ministre.
Hier, notre Assemblée s'est
prononcée souverainement.
Ce choix mérite
le respect
et en aucun cas l'insulte.
Nous insulter, madame
la Première ministre,
c'est insulter les Français.
Notre Assemblée
a rappelé une vérité.
Vous êtes minoritaires
dans cette Assemblée.
Notre Assemblée
a sanctionné
dans la forme le mépris
insupportable
du ministre
de l'Intérieur,
qui cède depuis hier,
perdant ses nerfs,
à la caricature et à l'insulte.
Notre Assemblée
a sanctionné, au-delà,
sur le fond, un texte
contradictoire
qui consacrait le "en même
temps" politique,
symbole de l'impuissance
et de l'immobilisme.
Votre "en même temps"
migratoire voulait
tout à la fois
la régularisation massive
de clandestins et l'expulsion
d'autres clandestins.
Cela est naturellement
irresponsable
et incohérent.
C'est pour cela
que nous n'avons
pas souhaité poursuivre
ce faux-semblant
de débat.
C'est pour cela
que nous avons voulu installer
le débat sur d'autres bases.
Contrairement
à ce que vous avez dit,
ce débat,
il va se poursuivre
sur un texte très clair,
celui approuvé
par les sénateurs.
C'est ce texte
que nous vous invitons
à soutenir.
C'est le seul
que nous soutiendrons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Monsieur le président
Eric Ciotti,
les Français attendent
des réponses face
aux enjeux migratoires.
Vous le savez.
Ils exigent
des solutions efficaces
pour éloigner plus rapidement
les personnes
en situation irrégulière
et mieux intégrer
ceux que nous accueillons.
Les Français approuvent
les mesures portées
par notre projet
de loi, des mesures
qui facilitent l'expulsion
des étrangers délinquants,
de ceux qui constituent
une menace
pour l'ordre public.
Ce sont des mesures
qui simplifient
nos procédures,
qui renforcent les sanctions
contre les passeurs.
Ces mesures, nous en avons besoin.
Elles sont attendues
par nos concitoyens
et enrichies par le Sénat
et la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale.
Elles sont celles
portées
par notre projet de loi.
Je salue ici
l'engagement du ministre
de l'Intérieur
et je lui dis
toute ma confiance.
Je veux saluer tous
les parlementaires
qui ont choisi
de construire plutôt
que de s'opposer
par principe,
qui ont choisi
le débat plutôt
que le coup d'éclat.
Monsieur Eric Ciotti,
vous appelez
à des débats au Parlement
sur l'immigration.
Pourtant, hier,
avec la NUPES
et le Rassemblement
National,
vous avez refusé le débat.
Vous avez refusé le débat
mais les défis restent
et les attentes
des Français sont intactes.
Nous avons besoin
de solutions
et d'un texte rapidement.
Notre détermination
ne faiblit pas.
Comme pour tous les textes,
nous cherchons
des compromis.
Comme pour plus de 50
textes
depuis 18 mois,
nous savons
que nous pouvons y parvenir.
Nous respectons les règles
de la démocratie parlementaire...
Huées
Nous avons décidé de convoquer
une commission mixte paritaire
rapidement
pour trouver un accord
sur un texte qui doit
pouvoir trouver
une majorité au Sénat
comme à l'Assemblée nationale.
La volonté de donner
des réponses efficaces reste
notre objectif.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Erwan Balanant.
- Erwan Balanant: Merci.
Vendredi dernier,
une professeur
de français
a illustré son cours
sur "Les métamorphoses"
d'Ovide
avec la présentation
d'un tableau
de Giuseppe Cesari.
Il s'agissait d'une
manière de lier
deux arts: la peinture
et la littérature.
Depuis, cette professeure
et l'ensemble
de l'équipe éducative
ont demandé
à bénéficier
de leur droit de retrait.
En cause: des élèves
se sont insurgés
contre des propos
ressentis comme racistes.
Ils ont depuis reconnu
que ces accusations
étaient mensongères.
Trop tard, le mal était fait.
Il ne s'agit pas d'un simple
fait divers.
Cette situation
illustre un problème
plus profond
dans nos écoles,
celui de la remise
en question
de notre principe de laïcité.
Ce sont bien vos mots
que je fais miens aujourd'hui,
monsieur le ministre.
"A l'école
française,
on ne conteste pas
l'autorité,
on la respecte.
A l'école
française,
on ne conteste pas
la laïcité,
on la respecte."
Ce sont des propos
que nous devrions
tous saluer.
Notre pays,
héritier des Lumières
et de l'universalisme,
ne peut se laisser enfermer
dans de telles attaques.
Nous devons défendre
notre principe
de laïcité,
qui impose le respect
de toutes les croyances,
l'égalité
de tous les citoyens
devant la loi,
sans distinction
de religion et la garantie
du libre exercice des cultes.
Le principe de la laïcité
est un pilier
de notre société.
Pour nos enfants,
l'école est un lieu
de son apprentissage.
Ils doivent accepter
d'y construire
leur esprit critique
sans rejeter
ce qu'ils apprennent
au nom
de leur religion,
quelle qu'elle soit.
Réaffirmons ensemble
notre soutien
à l'ensemble
des professeurs menacés
et remercions-les
pour leur courage
et leur engagement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gabriel
Attal, ministre
de l'Education nationale.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Balanant, il faut
en revenir à l'essentiel.
Le rôle de l'école
française,
c'est de former des républicains.
Notre école
a des racines
et dans ces racines,
il y a la laïcité,
l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes
et l'autorité de l'enseignant.
Je le redis,
monsieur le député,
même si certains
cherchent à provoquer
ces racines ou à déraciner
notre école,
ces racines sont solides.
Elles sont portées
chaque jour
par des centaines
de milliers d'enseignants
qui démocratisent
le savoir au service
de notre pays.
Je le redis
ici
devant vous comme je l'ai
dit hier
aux enseignants du collège
Jacques-Cartier d'Issou.
Jamais je n'accepterai
qu'on refuse
de regarder
un tableau à l'école
de la République,
que l'on se bouche
les oreilles
en cours de musique
ou que l'on s'en prenne
à un enseignant.
J'ai placé mon action
sous le sceau
de l'efficacité.
Je ne prends pas
des positions,
mais des décisions
et je les fait appliquer.
Sous l'autorité
de la Première ministre
du président,
c'est pour cela
que j'ai décidé
d'interdire le port
de l'abaya
à l'école
et que j'ai fait respecter
cette interdiction.
C'est pour cela que j'ai décidé
de sanctionner
les élèves qui ont contesté
le moment d'hommage
à la mémoire de Samuel Paty
et de Dominique Bernard.
C'est pour cela
que j'ai dit
que les élèves
responsables
de cette situation au collège
d'Issou seraient sanctionnés.
Il y aura des sanctions
disciplinaires.
Monsieur le député,
c'est un combat difficile,
mais je sais
que nous gagnerons ce combat
pour l'école
de la République
et notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la présidente Cyrielle Chatelain.
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
les écologistes
sont fiers d'avoir porté
une motion
de rejet contre un texte
qui affaiblissait
les droits des étrangers
et reprenait
les obsessions identitaires
de l'extrême droite.
Les écologistes
sont fiers d'avoir porté
une motion de rejet
contre un texte
qui voulait
restreindre les titres
de séjour
pour les étrangers malades
et durcir les conditions
d'accueil
pour les étudiants
ou les étrangers malades.
Les députés d'extrême droite
ont apprécié l'ouverture
du gouvernement
sur la modification
du texte.
Dans le texte,
il y avait le retour
du délit de séjour irrégulier.
Les manoeuvres n'ont pas suffi.
Votre texte a été
démocratiquement rejeté.
Mais que dire
des méthodes crapuleuses
de votre ministre de l'Intérieur?
Votre ministre
de l'Intérieur a tenté
de marchander les votes
des parlementaires
contre des gendarmeries.
Votre ministre de l'Intérieur
s'est vanté ici
de ficher les députés
du groupe LR
qui demandent des régularisations.
Pourquoi,
si ce n'est pour faire
du chantage?
Madame la Première
ministre, retirez
le texte
ou acceptez
que ce soit votre ministre
de l'Intérieur
qui dicte les méthodes
de votre gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Madame la présidente
Chatelain, j'entends
que vous êtes fière
d'avoir refusé
le débat sur un texte
très largement soutenu
par nos compatriotes.
Vous êtes fière
d'avoir fait voter
une motion de rejet
grâce à l'aide
de l'extrême droite.
Vous êtes fière de faire
passer le cynisme
et l'incohérence
avant vos principes.
Vous êtes fière de priver
nos concitoyens
d'un texte qu'ils attendent.
A votre place,
je ne serais pas fière.
Vous cherchez à bloquer
le fonctionnement
de nos institutions.
Vous n'avez prouvé
qu'une chose:
vous avez une majorité
de blocage
mais pas une majorité d'action.
Vous avez une majorité
pour empêcher,
mais pas pour gouverner.
Avec Gérald Darmanin
et mon gouvernement,
nous ne renoncerons
jamais à agir
au service des Français.
C'est pourquoi,
malgré vos calculs politiciens
et vos alliances
contre nature,
nous continuerons à miser
sur le débat parlementaire
et la responsabilité
des élus
de la nation.
Une commission mixte
paritaire sera convoquée.
Nous continuerons
à chercher un accord
sur ce texte
et des solutions
pour les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la présidente?
- Cyrielle Chatelain:
La majorité parlementaire
a pu compter sur les voix
de l'extrême droite
pour près de 50%
des textes présentés
par votre gouvernement.
Est-ce que vous jeté
la loi
sur les JO?
On va toujours
défendre le droit
de vote des étrangers, l'AME,
l'hébergement d'urgence.
Vous aviez un choix
entre le retrait
du texte et le déshonneur.
Il n'y aura pas de texte
et vous gardez
le déshonneur.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Benjamin Saint-Huile.
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Merci.
Je m'excuse par avance.
Ma question ne traitera pas
de la problématique migratoire
parce qu'en France,
il y a d'autres priorités.
La priorité numéro
1 des Français,
c'est la question
du pouvoir d'achat.
Partout en France,
que vous soyez travailleur,
salarié, retraité
ou étudiant,
elle reste
la problématique majeure.
Au nom du groupe LIOT,
je veux interroger
le gouvernement
pour connaître sa position.
Je veux interroger
le ministre Olivier Dussopt
et lui parler de la France
qui travaille
et qui ne s'en sort plus.
Les chiffres récents
ont été annoncés.
17% des travailleurs
du pays
sont des smicards.
Jamais ce chiffre n'a été
aussi important.
Au-delà de ces 17%,
les travailleurs pauvres
sont de plus en plus nombreux.
Ils sont rattrapés
par un SMIC qui n'évolue
plus et des salaires bas.
Vous avez mis en place
une conférence sociale
sur les salaires
mais vous avez limité
la discussion aux 39
branches qui pratiquent
des minima en dessous du SMIC.
Ma question est la suivante.
Quelles mesures concrètes,
rapides, urgentes,
le gouvernement compte
mettre en place
pour permettre aux bas salaires
d'enfin progresser
et rendre de la fierté
à ceux qui veulent simplement
vivre de leur travail?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Saint-Huile,
vous m'interrogez
sur la question
du pouvoir d'achat
et l'évolution
des salaires.
Vous parlez particulièrement
des bas salaires.
Vous avez raison
de rappeler
que nous avons un mécanisme
d'indexation
du SMIC qui a permis,
depuis janvier 2021,
de voir le SMIC augmenter 7 fois.
C'est une augmentation
au total de 13,5%
qui a protégé
le pouvoir d'achat
des salariés les plus modestes.
Cela explique le chiffre
de 17% de salariés
au SMIC au 1er janvier 2023.
Dès lors que le SMIC
augmente rapidement,
il est assez logique
que les plus basses rémunérations
soient rattrapées.
Nous ne devons pas laisser
s'installer
cette situation.
A l'occasion
de la conférence sociale
que nous avons organisée,
nous avons indiqué
que nous souhaitions
ouvrir deux chantiers.
Le premier,
c'est sur la question
des classifications.
C'est un peu technique,
mais ça relève
du dialogue de branches
et de la capacité qu'ont
les branches
professionnelles à prévoir
des gradations
salariales en fonction
de l'ancienneté
et des compétences,
pour permettre
des carrières
avec des progressions
salariales
et non pas une stagnation
au début
de la carrière.
Nous devons aussi
faire attention
à ce que les branches
professionnelles
qui ont en charge
la discussion sociale
autour des salaires...
Car vous le savez,
ce n'est pas la loi
qui détermine
le niveau du SMIC
mais ce sont les partenaires
sociaux
qui fixent les niveaux
conventionnels.
Nous devons faire en sorte
que les branches soient
plus actives.
J'ai réuni hier
un comité de suivi
des négociations salariales
et je reçois demain
les plus en retard
en matière de mise
en conformité.
Nous mettons en oeuvre
tous les outils
dont nous disposons.
Nous envisageons
des textes dès 2024
pour sanctionner
les branches
qui ne se sont pas mises
en conformité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Une réponse?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile:
Reconnaissons
que ça n'est pas suffisant.
Est-ce qu'on pourrait, ici,
étudier l'hypothèse
de supprimer
les cotisations salariales
chez les bas salaires
et de les faire peser
sur les hauts revenus?
Ca donnerait de l'argent
aux Français
qui travaillent
et qui n'arrivent
pas à finir le mois.
Ce serait de la justice sociale.
On ferait peser
sur les plus hauts salaires
les efforts.
Il est temps de répartir
les richesses.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Laure Miller.
- Laure Miller: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
Hier, un peu avant 18h,
une sorte
de conjuration
des aigris a décidé,
contre l'avis
des Français, d'empêcher
tout débat
sur un des plus grands défis
de notre siècle: l'immigration.
270 parlementaires
ont décidé de censurer
le Parlement.
Alors même que vous passez
votre temps
à nous donner des leçons
de démocratie,
vous avez,
sous le regard perplexe
des Français,
fêté la muselière
que vous êtes vous-même
accrochée
et mis à la poubelle
vos amendements.
C'est un formidable
coup médiatique.
Et après?
J'entends que le "en même
temps" serait
un échec.
Vous nous rappelez sans cesse
à la composition éclectique
de notre Assemblée.
Par définition,
il nous faut faire
des compromis.
Tous nos voisins européens
sont assez responsables
pour le faire.
Vous avez montré
hier
que vous n'en étiez pas capable.
Vous préférez la paralysie
à l'action responsable.
Les Français sont donc
privés de débat
sur un texte qu'ils plébiscitent.
Nous avons besoin de ce texte.
Nous avons besoin
d'expulser plus facilement
les délinquants étrangers
qui représentent
une menace pour les Français.
Nous avons besoin
de retirer leur titre
de séjour à ceux qui adhèrent
à l'islam radical.
Nous devons simplifier
les procédures
en nous inspirant des rapports
du sénateur Buffet.
Nos policiers
et gendarmes ont besoin
de pouvoir inspecter
les véhicules
aux frontières pour lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine.
Nous avons besoin
de ce texte pour armer
notre justice
contre les passeurs
et les marchands de sommeil.
Nous en avons besoin
pour supprimer
la présence de mineurs
dans les centres
de rétention administrative.
Un de vos prédécesseurs
disait
qu'il ne fallait pas
craindre
de se faire des ennemis...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, madame
la députée Miller.
Ce qui est certain,
c'est que ce
sont les policiers,
les gendarmes...
Vous les avez déjà
privés de moyens.
Ce n'est pas la peine
de les humilier
en public et de les huer.
Les policiers, les gendarmes,
les magistrats,
les agents
de préfecture,
qui ne sont pas dans les petits
jeux
de la bouillie
politicienne
avec le RN qui vote
avec la NUPES....
Je pense au maire de Menton.
Il réclame des moyens
supplémentaires
qui étaient prévus
dans le projet
de loi avec notamment
l'inspection
des véhicules qui traversent
la frontière.
Aujourd'hui,
les policiers
ne peuvent pas regarder
les coffres
sans le projet de loi.
Je pense à tous ceux qui luttent
l'immigration irrégulière
et les passeurs.
Je pense à la courageuse
maire de Calais,
qui réclame
depuis longtemps
que ce soit un crime
pour les passeurs
et non pas un délit.
Je pense à tous ces policiers,
ces gendarmes,
ces élus
et ces magistrats,
qui ont dû regarder, éplorés,
l'Assemblée nationale,
qui est censée
discuter, amender
et adopter,
refuser d'accomplir
son rôle.
Nous allons continuer
à travailler, pourtant.
Nous regardons l'intérêt général.
Nous avons un texte ferme et fort.
C'est sans doute
pour cela
qu'il n'a pas voulu être discuté.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Clémentine Autain.
- Clémentine Autain:
Madame la ministre,
des dizaines
et des dizaines de milliers
de Palestiniens ont été tués
par l'armée israélienne
à Gaza, sans compter
les meurtres perpétrés
par les colons
de Cisjordanie,
sans compter
les effets du blocus
avec le manque d'eau potable,
d'électricité,
de soins,
et sans compter
encore les 86
journalistes assassinés.
Depuis les 1200 civils
israéliens massacrés
par le Hamas le 7 octobre,
le gouvernement
de Benyamin Netanyahou
précipite
la région dans une boucherie
sans nom,
au mépris du droit international.
Hier, le leader
de la diplomatie
de l'Union
Européenne alertait
sur la situation à Gaza,
la qualifiant d'apocalyptique.
Il faut dire que les bombardements
s'appuient désormais
sur l'intelligence
artificielle,
qui n'est jamais
que la créature
de son maître, appliquant
la consigne morbide
de n'avoir
aucune limite en termes
de victimes collatérales,
entendez évidemment d'assassinats
de civils.
Ce cauchemar doit cesser.
Le veto posé
vendredi à l'ONU
sur une résolution
pour un cessez-le-feu largement
plébiscité montre combien
les Etats-Unis protègent
en toutes circonstances Israël,
et combien
le fonctionnement
de cette organisation
internationale nécessite aussi
d'être réformé.
Pour autant, aujourd'hui,
l'Assemblée générale
de l'ONU va exhorter
une nouvelle fois
la communauté
internationale à agir
en vertu de la responsabilité
de protéger.
Quelle sera la position
de la France?
Allez-vous sortir
des zigzags
pour que la parole
de la France
soit forte, cohérente,
déterminée,
que nous en finissions
avec ce décompte
des morts civils?
Allez-vous enfin
mobiliser l'ensemble
de notre diplomatie au service
du cessez-le-feu
à Gaza?
Quant à nous,
mes chers collègues,
nous marcherons
encore dimanche 17 décembre,
oui, une nouvelle
fois, pour la paix!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Catherine Colonna.
Monsieur Habib, s'il vous plaît.
Monsieur Habib, s'il vous plaît!
- Catherine Colonna:
Madame la députée Autain,
depuis le début
de la guerre déclenchée
par le Hamas le 7 octobre,
la France n'a cessé
de chercher à rassembler
la communauté internationale
autour de trois principes clairs.
Le premier, c'est le rejet
du terrorisme, toujours,
et la condamnation du Hamas,
organisation terroriste.
A ma demande,
avec l'Allemagne et l'Italie,
l'Union Européenne examine
un nouveau régime
de sanctions
contre ce groupe terroriste.
Le deuxième,
c'est la libération
de tous les otages,
dont nos quatre compatriotes
encore disparus
à Gaza.
Nous pensons tous à eux.
Le troisième,
c'est la protection
des populations civiles,
obligation morale autant
que juridique.
Cela signifie
apporter de l'aide
en quantité suffisante
aux populations civiles
de Gaza qui vivent
une tragédie, oui.
Ca signifie aussi obtenir
une pause humanitaire,
durable, menant
à un cessez-le-feu.
Sur ces bases, la France
a voté successivement
les projets
de résolution présentés
au Conseil de sécurité
par le Brésil,
les Etats-Unis d'Amérique,
les Emirats arabes unis,
textes qui n'ont pas pu
aboutir
du fait de veto,
mais d'autres textes
ont abouti à l'Assemblée générale.
Un autre projet de résolution sera
voté aujourd'hui
avec la voix de la France.
A chaque fois,
notre pays a oeuvré
pour dégager des solutions.
Il continuera
d'oeuvrer
pour que la communauté
internationale
se rassemble autour des questions
humanitaires,
de sécurité et d'une
solution politique,
la seule qui amènera la paix.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Anne-Laure Blin.
- Anne-Laure Blin: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
nos sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
sont admirables.
Engagés généreusement
dans le territoire,
ils assurent cette mission
de service public
qui garantit sécurité
et protection
à nos concitoyens.
C'est parce qu'ils s'engagent
sans compter
que le Parlement
a adopté,
il y a quelques mois,
des dispositions
pour reconnaître leur volontariat.
Alors,
il y a quelques semaines,
monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur annonçait
que le décret
portant bonification
de leur retraite
serait publié d'ici
la fin du mois.
Quelle ne fut pas ma surprise
lorsque,
durant les Sainte-Barbe
organisées partout
dans nos casernes,
nous avons découvert qu'en vérité,
le gouvernement
préparait un décret
pour le moins réducteur.
Nous avons appris
que votre gouvernement envisageait
de reconnaître l'engagement
des seuls sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires ayant
des carrières hachurées,
en excluant
ceux qui avaient une carrière
professionnelle
en parallèle
de leur engagement citoyen.
Comment pouvez-vous
sacrifier
ceux qui se donnent
avec générosité,
parfois au péril de leur vie?
Nos sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires
sont un maillon essentiel
de nos secours.
Ils sont essentiels
dans nos territoires ruraux.
Ils agissent chaque jour
avec un engagement
sans faille,
avec le soutien
de leur famille.
Reconnaître et valoriser
leur engagement,
c'était la volonté du législateur.
Ce décret bafoue la volonté
du peuple affirmée
dans cet hémicycle.
Il trompe nos sapeurs-pompiers.
Pouvez-vous nous garantir
très solennellement
que votre gouvernement
fera
tout pour faire respecter
scrupuleusement
la volonté
du législateur
et que tous
les sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires de France
seront reconnus
à leur juste valeur?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Madame la députée Blin,
je vous remercie
de remarquer
que c'est la majorité
actuelle qui va,
en effet, reconnaître
par un décret,
qui est encore au Conseil
d'Etat
et qui n'est pas encore publié.
Il va en effet
reconnaître l'engagement
de nos sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires
et il va appliquer
la loi strictement,
comme il l'aura fait
sur tous les amendements
qui auront été
présentés lorsque
la loi a été adoptée.
Vous pourrez
compter sur moi
en tant que ministre
pour appliquer strictement
la loi et respecter
l'engagement
de nos sapeurs-pompiers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Blin?
- Anne-Laure Blin:
La volonté du législateur,
c'est de couvrir l'ensemble
des sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
de ce pays.
Il n'est pas question
que seul 10%
des sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
soient destinataires
de cela et bénéficient
de retraites
et de bonifications.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin:
Nous l'entendons bien,
madame la députée.
C'est pour ça
que nous y travaillons.
Peut-être qu'il aurait été
mieux d'attendre
le décret
sorti
par le gouvernement
avant de le commenter,
ou peut-être considérez-vous,
alors, si cela correspond
à l'engagement
que nous avons eu,
que vous devrez
tout cela au président
de la République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Caroline Parmentier.
- Caroline Parmentier:
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre de la Culture.
Lors d'une
conférence de presse
qui aurait pu
passer inaperçu,
vous avez lancé
le programme la Relève
en partenariat
avec Sciences Po,
visant à renouveler
les postes de direction
du monde de la culture.
En plus de l'origine
géographique
et sociale,
vous proposez, au nom
de la diversité,
de prendre notamment
en compte "le critère
de la couleur
de peau" dans ce recrutement.
Ce que vous proposez
là,
c'est de la discrimination.
Sur la base
de critères ethniques,
c'est du racisme.
Le racisme est une infraction
à la loi française.
Pire, c'est une insulte
à nos valeurs.
Jusqu'à présent,
au nom de l'article 6
de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme
qui dispose que tous
les citoyens
sont également
admissibles
à toutes dignités,
places et emplois publics
selon leur capacité
et sans autre distinction
que celle
de leurs vertus
et de leurs talents,
la France s'était refusée
à suivre la voie
du racialisme américain.
En France, seule
la compétence justifie
une nomination et constitue
le seul critère légitime
et légal pour départager
des candidats
à une fonction administrative
et culturelle.
Pouvez-vous
nous expliquer
quel est le sens
de cette proposition
et ce qu'elle signifie?
Est-ce que cela veut
dire
qu'il y a trop de Blancs
parmi les dirigeants
de la culture?
Après vos sorties
contre C8 et CNews,
à qui vous vouliez
retirer la fréquence,
après votre réaction
très gênée
sur l'AFP et le Hamas,
après Bastien Vivès,
et maintenant ce fait
dans le recrutement
dans la culture,
où voulez-vous exactement
nous emmener?
Où voulez-vous emmener
la culture française?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Rima Abdul Malak.
- Rima Abdul Malak:
Madame la députée,
ce n'est pas la première
fois
que votre groupe
s'illustre en fabrication
de fake news.
Encore une fois,
vous démontrez
que vous n'avez
aucune considération
pour la réalité.
Si vous aviez pris
le temps de regarder
la conférence de presse
que vous mentionnez
du lancement
de cette initiative
qui s'appelle à la Relève,
vous auriez pu constater
que tout ce que vous dites
est faux.
Je n'ai pas parlé de critères.
J'ai précisé plusieurs fois
que j'entendais "diversité"
au sens "diversité sociale
et géographique".
C'est même le titre du programme.
La Relève,
c'est une initiative
pour accélérer
l'égalité des chances,
pour former un jeune
par département,
à intégrer les métiers
de la culture
et élargir les recrutements.
Pourquoi la diversité
vous fait-elle peur?
Qu'est-ce qui vous fait peur?
Cette diversité,
c'est une richesse
pour la France.
C'est une chance
pour l'avenir
de nos institutions culturelles.
Au-delà des attaques
personnelles,
la plus grande fake
news aujourd'hui,
c'est quoi?
La plus grande
manipulation aujourd'hui,
12 décembre, c'est quoi?
C'est que vous,
le Rassemblement National,
vous voulez
nous faire croire
que vous êtes devenus
le parti à l'avant-garde
de la lutte
contre les discriminations
et la lutte contre le racisme.
Vous?
Non mais sérieusement!
Vous, le parti
de la stigmatisation permanente?
Vous qui n'avez
que l'obsession identitaire
à la bouche?
Vous qui traitez
un député de racaille
et qui hurlez
à un autre de retourner
en Afrique?
Vous et vos frères
d'armes de Reconquête
qui veulent changer
les prénoms
de ceux qui ont un nom
comme le mien,
à consonance étrangère?
C'est ça qui vous fait
peur,
c'est cette diversité.
C'est ça, la grande manipulation.
C'est au-delà du cynisme
et de l'hypocrisie.
Mais les Français
ne seront pas dupes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Parmentier?
- Caroline Parmentier:
Je note
votre fébrilité.
J'ai regardé
votre conférence de presse,
et vous avez parlé
de couleur de peau.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
c'est terminé.
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Guillaume Gouffier Valente.
- Guillaume Gouffier
Valente: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
au garde des Sceaux,
ministre de la Justice.
Il y a quelques semaines,
une de mes collègues interrogeait
la Première ministre
sur le projet
de loi constitutionnel visant
à garantir pleinement
la liberté de recourir à l'IVG.
A cette occasion,
le gouvernement indiquait
que ce texte serait
présenté en Conseil
des ministres avant la fin
de l'année.
C'est désormais chose
faite, et je tiens,
au nom de notre groupe,
à vous féliciter
pour le respect
de ce calendrier
pour cet engagement
tellement essentiel.
A ce titre, permettez-moi
de rappeler pourquoi
ce texte est majeur.
A l'heure où certains tentent
d'en minimiser malheureusement
la portée,
dans notre pays mais aussi
en Europe et dans le monde,
disons-le clairement,
les forces
réactionnaires
qui ont pour objectif
de remettre
en cause l'avortement,
son accès
pour toutes les femmes,
son fondement même,
grandissent.
Prenons garde.
Il ne le diront
jamais comme tel,
mais une fois au pouvoir,
ces partis conservateurs
extrémistes feront
tout pour dévoyer,
entraver, presque
annihiler l'avortement,
son accès le plus essentiel.
Dans ce cadre,
qui pourra considérer
que tous moyens visant
à le garantie
ne serait pas utile
dans sa constitutionnalisation?
Notre pays,
celui des libertés
et des Lumières,
celui de Gisèle Halimi
et de Simone Veil,
sera le premier
au monde à inscrire
cette liberté fondamentale
dans sa Constitution,
ce qui enverra
un message clair et unique
au monde entier.
Une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
avait été votée
à l'Assemblée nationale puis
au Sénat et le gouvernement
présente désormais
une troisième voie d'écriture.
Pouvez-vous nous préciser
la philosophie
de cette écriture?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti:
Monsieur le député,
le projet de loi
constitutionnel relatif
à la liberté de recourir
à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse a été
présenté ce matin
en Conseil des ministres.
Ce projet de loi
est un engagement fort
du président de la République,
de l'ensemble
du gouvernement,
mais il est aussi
le résultat
de l'engagement total
du Parlement
et de l'Assemblée nationale.
Je veux saluer ici
cette mobilisation,
la vôtre,
monsieur le député,
celle de tous les députés
de la majorité
et de l'opposition
qui ont rendu possible
cette nouvelle étape.
Mais une révision
constitutionnelle nécessite
un vote identique
à l'Assemblée
et au Sénat, qui ont,
pour l'instant,
adopté deux versions différentes.
L'écriture retenue
fait converger
les deux versions.
La voici.
"La loi détermine
les conditions
dans lesquelles s'exerce
la liberté garantie
à la femme d'avoir recours
à une interruption volontaire
de grossesse."
Cette écriture issue
du Conseil d'Etat permet
de respecter le renvoi
à la loi voulue
par les deux assemblées,
tout en inscrivant
dans la Constitution
que la liberté
d'avoir recours
à l'IVG, c'était
le souhait du Sénat,
serait garantie,
c'était le souhait
de votre assemblée.
Il s'agit là d'une
occasion historique
que nous avons collectivement
rendue possible.
Il nous faut désormais
aller au bout.
Si la route est encore longue,
les débats,
ce mot-là prend aujourd'hui
un sens particulier,
seront riches.
Mais ne perdons pas notre objectif
commun.
Nul ne doit pouvoir
retirer aux femmes
le droit de disposer
de leur corps.
Je serai le 16 janvier
en commission.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Elsa Faucillon.
- Elsa Faucillon: Merci.
Hier, les députés
d'opposition ont adopté
la motion de rejet
du texte immigration
que vous portez depuis un an.
Notre groupe l'a voté
en responsabilité,
résolument opposé à ce texte
qui allait fabriquer
plus de précarité
et de misère, voté aussi
pour mettre fin
aux propos racistes
et xénophobes
tenus au sein même
de notre Parlement,
voté enfin
parce que les débats
autour de ce texte
ne font
que fracturer un peu
plus notre pays.
Il n'y a pas de France,
comme le prétendent
les promoteurs du choc
de civilisation,
mais bien un peuple
en quête d'unité
autour de l'égalité.
Notre pays souffre d'une
crise de l'accueil.
C'est vrai
pour les exilés,
mais c'est aussi vrai
dans nos crèches
et nos EHPAD,
dans nos écoles
et nos hôpitaux,
dans nos commissariats
et nos préfectures.
Les étrangers
n'en sont pas responsables.
En revanche,
vos choix politiques
qui visent à préserver
les intérêts
des plus riches,
oui, elles le sont.
L'explication
par le bouc émissaire
est depuis toujours l'ossature
de l'extrême droite.
Les soi-disant
"républicains"
lui ont emboité
le pas,
mais c'est bien
un président
de la République
qui a assumé de présenter
une énième loi
sur l'immigration,
validant des thèses aussi
répugnantes qu'infondées.
Vous avez hier essuyé
une lourde défaite.
Elle n'est finalement
que la réalité
qui devait s'imposer à vous.
Vous n'avez pas de majorité.
Après vingt 49.3,
vous n'avez
aucune leçon à donner
au Parlement
en matière de débat.
Car en démocratie,
le rejet d'hier s'impose
à vous.
Cessez de fracturer le pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Madame la députée Faucillon,
vous connaissez
bien ce texte,
vous l'avez suivi
en tant que commissaire loi,
et ce assidûment.
Vous avez finalement
choisi de voter
la motion de rejet
avec le Rassemblement National
sur un texte qui prévoyait
l'interdiction
de la présence
des mineurs
dans les centres
de rétention administratif.
Ce que jamais
la gauche n'a fait,
même
quand les communistes
étaient de responsabilité.
Des enfants dans les centres
de rétention administratif.
Nous avons choisi,
en lien avec la gauche
du Sénat, en lien avec vous,
de pouvoir faire
une avancée
que tout le monde
réclamait,
et vous avez voté
une motion de rejet
avec madame Le Pen.
Vous avez voté
avec madame Le Pen
pour mettre fin
à la régularisation
de travailleurs
qui ne demandent rien d'autre
que de vivre dans la République.
Vous avez voté
avec madame Le Pen
pour éviter que les marchands
de sommeil soient combattus
contre vos propres
avancées communistes
au Sénat.
Vous avez préféré manifestement
le petit coup politique,
et demain, vous savez
ce que vous aurez:
un texte
qui ne correspondra pas
aux dispositions
qu'on aurait pu
avoir avec vous.
Vous avez choisi vos intérêts
politiques politiciens
à toutes ces personnes
qui étaient jusqu'à présent
dans les centres
de rétention administratifs,
mais ça
ne changera pas grand-chose.
Depuis que je suis ministre,
je le fais.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Hadrien Ghomi.
- Hadrien Ghomi:
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale
et de la Jeunesse,
l'école est le socle
de notre société.
Elle accompagne
nos enfants sur le chemin
de la citoyenneté.
A l'heure où les valeurs
républicaines
sont menacées,
attaquées, l'uniforme
est l'une des réponses
aux besoins
de symboles communs
grâce auxquelles
notre jeunesse
apprend à faire bloc.
La tenue unique
est l'expression
du principe selon lequel chacun,
indépendamment
de son origine sociale,
de sa couleur
de peau, de sa religion
ou de son orientation sexuelle,
est dépositaire
des mêmes droits
et des mêmes devoirs.
Cela honore ainsi la promesse
républicaine qu'une place
soit accordée
à tous, à l'école
comme au sein
de notre communauté nationale.
Si l'uniforme
n'est pas la solution miracle
à toutes les difficultés
auxquelles l'école
est confrontée,
partout où il existe déjà,
le constat est identique:
il participe
à la lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire.
Il contribue à un sentiment
d'appartenance
et amène chaque élève
à s'enorgueillir d'une culture
valorisée, commune et partagée.
En Nouvelle-Calédonie,
la province Sud a généralisé
la tenue scolaire commune
il y a 7 ans
et les retours
sont plus que positifs.
90% des parents
sont satisfaits,
et là où le vêtement
était un marqueur différenciant,
l'uniforme a contribué
à amoindrir
la manifestation
des inégalités sociales.
Pour ces raisons,
nous nous réjouissons
de votre prise
de position audacieuse
sur ce sujet qui a trop longtemps
été caricaturé
et marginalisé.
Comme nous l'avons
fait à l'annonce
de la mesure
que vous avez prise
pour interdire
l'abaya à l'école,
nous soutenons aujourd'hui
la large expérimentation
que vous préconisez.
Par ailleurs, nous saluons
votre volonté exprimée
lors de vos récentes
déclarations
de ne pas faire
porter le coût
de cette expérimentation
sur les familles.
Pouvez-vous
nous en dire davantage
sur les modalités
pratiques de la mise
en place de cette expérimentation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Monsieur le député Hadrien Ghomi,
il y a en France des débats
qui durent éternellement,
qui déclenchent des discussions
parfois interminables
dans les familles
politiques,
tout court,
et je suis sûr
qu'il en sera de même
dans les soirées,
les fêtes,
encore cette année.
La question du port
de l'uniforme
à l'école fait partie
de ces débats.
J'y vois surtout l'attachement
des Français
à leur école et le souhait
très largement partagé
chez les Français
de toujours chercher
des solutions qui permettent
au climat scolaire
de s'améliorer
et au niveau de nos élèves
de s'élever.
Il y a donc
des débats réguliers
sur la question de savoir
si l'uniforme pourrait
être utile à l'apaisement
du climat scolaire
et à l'élévation
du niveau général
à l'école.
J'ai toujours
une obsession:
c'est de trancher et de décider.
Pour ça, je pense qu'il faut
faire progresser
le débat.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle
je suis favorable
à ce qu'il y ait
une expérimentation
de grande ampleur
sur la question
du port de l'uniforme
à l'école française.
Je pense que ça permettra
de mesurer si, oui
ou non, il y a un apport
réel s'agissant
du climat scolaire
et de l'élévation
du niveau.
La meilleure manière
de faire progresser
un débat
qui n'en finit pas
depuis des années,
c'est de tester
les choses.
J'ai vu qu'un certain nombre
de collectivités locales
de toutes couleurs
politiques confondues,
et j'insiste là-dessus,
ont d'ores
et déjà manifesté
leur intérêt
pour la participation
à cette expérimentation.
Ca va nous permettre
de faire progresser
le débat.
Nous aurons l'occasion
d'annoncer prochainement
les conditions
et le cadre
de cette
expérimentation,
mais notre motivation
est réelle,
pour faire progresser ce débat.
Notre seule boussole,
c'est d'élever
le niveau de nos élèves
et de garantir
un climat scolaire serein.
Je suis ravi que la majorité
nous accompagne
dans cet objectif.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Alexis Jolly.
- Alexis Jolly: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale
et de la Jeunesse,
jeudi dernier,
dans un collège des Yvelines,
la présentation
en classe d'un chef-d'oeuvre
de la Renaissance illustrant
une scène inspirée
de la mythologie grecque s'est
transformée en calvaire
pour une professeure,
insultée, menacée,
traitée de raciste
et d'islamophobe
par les élèves
et les parents.
Tous les jours,
les Français sont confrontés
à la montée
de ces revendications
islamistes
qui confrontent
avec violence
notre civilisation
et notre histoire.
Cette frénésie et ce rejet
des expressions artistiques
les plus sublimes
n'ont pas leur place
dans une France
qui est la mère
des arts.
Dans un récent
sondage de l'IFOP,
78% des musulmans
qui vivent
dans notre pays
disent considérer
la laïcité
comme discriminatoire
envers l'islam.
Non seulement la laïcité
s'est construite
non pas contre l'islam
mais contre l'Eglise,
mais aussi, au vu
du fait de changement
de socle civilisationnel
que l'immigration issus
des pays musulmans,
cela a été facilité
dans notre pays.
Depuis des décennies,
tous les gouvernements
dont vous êtes la continuité
ont échoué
dans leurs politiques
d'intégration.
Les Français
savent
qu'ils ne peuvent pas
compter
sur vous pour les défendre.
De son côté,
le Rassemblement National fera
du redressement
de la France
un de ses objectifs.
Marine Le Pen est avec nous.
La politique menée
par votre gouvernement met
en péril l'avenir de la France.
Etes-vous prêt à prendre
cette question
au sérieux?
Allez-vous enfin frapper
très fort réellement,
et non pas que symboliquement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Monsieur le député Jolly,
j'ai eu l'occasion
de répondre
tout à l'heure à une question
d'Erwan Balanant portant
sur le même sujet
et de réaffirmer
la détermination
qui est la mienne.
Oui,
il y a des ingérences,
il y a du séparatisme
islamiste
dans notre pays.
Je considère
que ma responsabilité
de ministre
de l'Education nationale
et de la Jeunesse,
c'est de faire
en sorte que l'école
reste toujours
un rempart face
à ces coups de boutoir
dans la République.
Là-dessus, je suis très clair.
Vous me pardonnerez,
j'espère, de considérer
à chaque fois
que je vous entends
vous exprimer
sur ce sujet
qu'il y a beaucoup
d'instrumentalisation
et de détermination.
Preuve en est:
dans votre question
de deux minutes,
vous n'avez pas eu
un seul mot
pour rappeler l'autorité
des enseignants et soutenir
les enseignants
qui sont en première
ligne face
à ces difficultés.
Pas un mot, monsieur le député.
J'ai de la mémoire.
A chaque fois que nous fermons
un lieu séparatiste
dans notre pays,
j'ai en mémoire
le fait que votre présidente
de groupe
avait refusé
de voter la loi
qui nous permet de fermer
ces établissements.
A chaque fois que nous prenons
des décisions
contre le séparatisme
à l'école,
j'ai en mémoire
que votre présidente
de groupe
n'avait pas voulu voter
la loi sur l'école de 2019.
A chaque fois
que je me réjouis
qu'il n'y ait
plus d'abaya dans l'école
de la République,
j'ai en mémoire
que les députés
de votre groupe
avaient perturbé
le travail du proviseur
à la rentrée
pour faire interdire
ce qui avait été dénoncé
par les équipes.
Derrière les propos
d'estrade,
il y a ceux qui agissent.
Nous n'agissons pas
grâce à vous,
mais malgré vous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Alexis Corbière.
- Alexis Corbière:
Je souhaite
vous interroger sur l'avenir
de 627.000 élèves,
soit près de 30%
d'une classe d'âge,
sur l'avenir des lycées
professionnels.
Ils accueillent
cette jeunesse issue
des milieux populaires,
aux parents généralement ouvriers,
employés.
L'enseignement professionnel
est aujourd'hui mobilisé
pour s'opposer
à vos projets,
et nous saluons
cette mobilisation.
Je résumerai
votre projet
par un fait choquant
et parlant:
vous voulez supprimer
170 heures d'enseignement
en 3 ans.
Pour nos élèves
en bac professionnel,
170 heures de moins.
En 2009 déjà,
le bac professionnel
est passé de 4 à 3 ans.
A cause de vous, en 2018,
Jean-Michel Blanquer
a supprimé 30%
d'enseignement général
et professionnel,
et vous continuez
ce saccage.
Vous remplacez
les heures volées
par plus de stages
en entreprise,
alors que nos élèves
y passent déjà
de nombreuses semaines.
Vous supprimez
des enseignements
de professeurs qualifiés
en entretenant
le mythe de l'entreprise
formatrice,
qui remplacerait
l'apport pédagogique
du professeur.
Toute l'histoire
de la République
a travaillé pour sortir
de l'enseignement
d'un terrain privé,
pour le confier
à l'école publique,
garante de l'intérêt général,
et vous faites l'inverse.
Les futurs travailleurs
et travailleuses
ont besoin d'une
qualification exigeante,
de diplômes reconnus
et de professeurs
qui les transmettent.
Retirez cette réforme,
rendez les heures
aux élèves de l'enseignement
professionnel.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Carole Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Monsieur le député Corbière,
effectivement,
c'est la ministre
en charge de l'enseignement
professionnel
qui vous répond.
Peut-être pensez-vous
que ces jeunes
ont confiance,
sont rassurés quant
à leur devenir,
que les taux de décrochage
d'insertion professionnelle
et de poursuite d'études
les encouragent
à être rassurés
dans le système
du lycée professionnel.
Pour la première fois,
le gouvernement
se mobilise pour que le lycée
professionnel
soit une voie
de choix, une voix
qui permette de construire
l'avenir souhaité
pour ces jeunes.
J'engage pleinement
les lycées professionnels
dans le choc des savoirs.
Eux aussi
doivent pouvoir
avoir plus d'enseignements
fondamentaux.
Ils ont pris 10%
d'enseignements fondamentaux.
Je propose un tiers
en plus en mathématiques,
histoire-géo, éducation civique.
Nous allons
également travailler
par des sous-effectifs
dès la 2nde
pour faire mieux
en maths et en français,
sur l'ensemble
de notre système scolaire.
L'année de terminale repensée
va permettre cela.
Nous allons aussi encourager
les formations d'avenir.
Placer les lycées
professionnels
dans un avenir,
c'est les placer
dans une grande stratégie.
Nous allons faire du lien
avec les entreprises
au travers du mentorat,
du bureau
des entreprises,
avec un enjeu d'attractivité
des filières.
Ces jeunes
le méritent
et nous avons travaillé pour cela.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Vous avez 4 secondes.
- Alexis Corbière: Pas de baratin.
Rendez les 170 heures.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Christophe Marion.
- Christophe Marion:
Après une troisième édition
réussie de la Semaine
des lycées professionnels,
j'adresse ma question à madame
Carole Grandjean.
Vous avez récemment
annoncé les contours
de la nouvelle
version de l'année
de terminale pour les élèves
de lycée professionnel.
Le calendrier serait
ainsi composé
de 30 semaines communes à tous.
A ce bloc commun
s'ajoutent 22 semaines
de cours et 6
de formation de stage.
6 semaines de cours
afin de préparer
à l'enseignement
supérieur
ceux qui ambitionnent
de poursuivre
leurs études.
Je salue la possibilité
qui sera offerte
aux élèves de modifier
leur choix
de parcours personnalisé
en fonction
de leurs premières
impressions
et de leurs résultats Parcoursup.
Votre proposition répond
aux besoins d'accompagnement,
à l'insertion
professionnelle des élèves
ainsi qu'à la nécessité
de faciliter
pour les lycéens
la poursuite d'études.
Mais vos annonces inquiètent
certains syndicats d'enseignants,
en témoigne
la grève en cours
dans nos établissements
professionnels.
Je sais
que vous êtes à l'écoute
de leurs préoccupations
et que vous les recevez
régulièrement
à votre ministère,
mais l'une
de leurs inquiétudes
est celle-ci:
pourront-ils trouver
des entreprises prêtes
à les accueillir
pour un stage de 6 semaines en fin
d'année scolaire
alors même que les 2nde
seront en stage
à la même période?
Trouveront-ils
des entreprises prêtes
à les embaucher
éventuellement
par la suite?
Une attention particulière
est-elle donc portée
aux lycées
professionnels situés
dans les bassins d'emploi
moins dynamiques?
Pouvez-vous nous rassurer
quant au respect
de l'équilibre
dans le cadre
de cette réforme
entre enseignement professionnel
et les enseignements généraux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à Carole Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean:
Monsieur le député
Christophe Marion,
je sais votre engagement
et votre attachement
à la jeunesse,
à l'école, et aux enjeux
de la ruralité.
Un tiers des lycéens passe
par la voie professionnelle.
Changer de paradigme,
c'est mieux
les faire réussir.
Seul 1 élève sur 2
parvient à s'insérer
dans l'emploi à l'issue
de son parcours
de formation.
Je prends toute ma part
dans le choc
des savoirs
pour que ces jeunes puissent
avoir une acquisition
des savoirs fondamentaux
qui leur permettrait
de travailler
leur citoyenneté
et leur avenir professionnel.
Il nous faut avancer dans le cadre
du dialogue social actuellement
en cours en maths, en français,
en histoire-géo,
en éducation
morale et civique,
pour mieux les préparer.
Autour d'un tronc
commun, ils seront
tous ensemble
pour réussir mieux
leur bac,
et on accompagne le projet
de l'élève
soit vers la poursuite
d'études,
soit sur un stage qui serait
un tremplin
vers le premier emploi.
Je souhaite
que nous travaillions
avec ces jeunes.
Je crois en la reconnaissance
de l'excellence
de ces jeunes.
Beaucoup
d'entre
eux sont dans cette démarche.
Il faut leur reconnaître
l'excellence.
Je souhaite aussi
valoriser le bureau
des entreprises
qui va nous aider
à travailler
tout au long de l'année
avec un dispositif spécial.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance de questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.